We now come to the third and
final kind of calculation out
of the calculations that
we carried out
in our earlier example.
The setting is exactly the same
as in our discussion of
the total probability theorem.
We have a sample space which is
partitioned into a number
of disjoint subsets
or events which
we think of as scenarios.
We're given the probability
of each scenario.
And we think of these
probabilities as being some
kind of initial beliefs.
They capture how likely we
believe each scenario to be.
Now, under each scenario, we
also have the probability that
an event of interest,
event B, will occur.
Then the probabilistic
experiment is carried out.
And perhaps we observe that
event B did indeed occur.
Once that happens, maybe this
should cause us to revise our
beliefs about the likelihood
of the different scenarios.
Having observed that B occurred,
perhaps certain
scenarios are more likely
than others.
How do we revise our beliefs?
By calculating conditional
probabilities.
And how do we calculate
conditional probabilities?
We start from the definition of
conditional probabilities.
The probability of one event
given another is the
probability that both events
occur divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event.
How do we continue?
We simply realize that the
numerator is what we can
calculate using the
multiplication rule.
And the denominator is exactly
what we calculate using the
total probability theorem.
So we have everything we need
to calculate those revised
beliefs, or conditional
probabilities.
And this all there is
in the Bayes rule.
It is actually a very
simple calculation.
It's a very simple
calculation.
However, it is a quite
important one.
Its history goes way back.
In the middle of the 18th
century, a Presbyterian
minister, Thomas Bayes,
worked it out.
It was published a few years
after his death.
And it was quickly reorganized
for its significance.
It's a systematic way for
incorporating new evidence.
learning from experience.
And it forms the foundation of a
major branch of mathematics,
so-called Bayesian inference,
which we will study in some
detail later in this course.
The general idea is that we
start with a probabilistic
model, which involves a number
of possible scenarios.
And we have some initial beliefs
on the likelihood of
each possible scenario.
There's also some particular
event that may occur under
each scenario.
And we know how likely it is to
occur under each scenario.
This is our model of
the situation.
Under each particular situation,
the model tells us
how likely event
B is to occur.
If we actually observe that B
occurred, then we use that
information to draw conclusions
about the possible
causes of B, or conclusions
about the more likely or less
likely scenarios that may have
caused this events to occur.
That's what inference is.
Having observed b, we make
inferences as to how likely a
particular scenario,
Ai, is going to be.
And that likelihood is captured
by this conditional
probabilities of Ai, given the
event B. So that's what the
Bayes rule is doing.
Starting from conditional
probabilities going in one
direction, it allows us to
calculate conditional
probabilities going in the
opposite direction.
It allows us to revise the
probabilities of the different
scenarios, taking into account
the new information.
And that's exactly what
inference is all about, as
we're going to see later
in this class.